but really my final word
here is
love we need it go do we need it or
not we need it and I don't you know I
just don't we need a gun that shoots
it we need a gun that shoots love if I
was
God if I was God I would just every it
would it would just be a big party over
there if I can make Israel a big party
if I could get every American
corporation to just go into the Gaza
Strip and just make it into a big mall
so that they could enjoy it everybody
could work at a Lowe's be
divorced you know because that's the
best the best reality in America is just
to work at a Lowe's and be
divorced and have a kid that doesn't
hate you I mean of sure people do better
than that here but on average on average
the best you can do in our country is to
work in a Lowe's that is located in an
outlet mall 45 minutes from your house
and have a daughter that doesn't
absolutely hate
you and you got a few nice friends at
the
lows you got a few nice
friends and you you don't see each other
that much out of work you did one time
but it was kind of weird you got a few
of the guys together and you went to a
restaurant called Yard House Google it
I'm not doing that whole thing again but
you went to Yard House and you got
chicken nachos and it was fun enough it
was fun
enough and you kind of see a woman who
you think might be seeing someone else
she said she'll never live with anyone
else again and never get remarried she
put the boundaries up immediately which
you thought was a little harsh up front
but you kind of like it now she's a
little cold and stares off she smokes a
lot and says she has no plans on
stopping that is the best you're going
to do in this country on average for the
most part you work at a Lowe's and
you're divorced you date a woman who's a
smoker and has no plans on stopping and
she says I like waking up
alone your daughter doesn't completely
hate you she pies you which you think
might be a little
worse but you're not bleeding out in the
Gaza
Strip and that's the
promise that we can make is if you get
it together out there you
Nots if you get it together relax with
the
religion on both sides relax with all
the Weaponry relax with the killing if
you're
lucky one day you will be driving alone
45 minutes to work in a
Lowe's your daughter will call you she
will say I'm going away for the weekend
but I'll call you when I get back I
really miss you I love you
Dad you will say thank you
honey you will put your phone
down that smoker that woman you're
dating will also call you she'll say I'm
around tonight that's as romantic as she
gets and you'll put your phone down
and you'll think to yourself you know
what it's not that bad and you'll never
see the teenage driver coming you'll
never see the teenage driver coming
you'll smile thinking about your
daughter and the somewhat mediocre sex
you'll have with that [__] later on
you'll never see that teenage driver
coming you'll hear the
smack and you'll feel the
glass and a few of those shards of glass
will get into your smile but you went
out nice you went out good and they'll
wonder where you are tonight at Lowe's
but they won't call you they won't call
you your phone won't ring and you knew
they wouldn't call you as you lay there
dying you go they won't call they'll
just think it's one of those
nights that's the American win so if you
get your [__] act together together
out there in the desert you could
have that